[Music]
rumor has it something's off at the
church
there's blood in the baptismal font and
pastor's gone missing and my genius plan
was to investigate it
alone
[Music]
of course
don't stress layla
[Music]
oh [__]
ugh
[Music]
what was that
he is the truth
he is
[Music]
oh
oh [__] there's more
jacob oh thank god come on let's find
the others and beat feet
you know
red fall used to look like it was
straight out of a postcard a picturesque
island off the coast of massachusetts
the bustling historic downtown the
seafront district and the old lighthouse
[Music]
then something happened
people started vanishing and those who
didn't sold out big time
fast forward basically everyone's either
a vampire a cult is trying to become a
vampire
we're dead
and these aren't just trashy movie
vampires these monsters blocked out the
sun and pushed back all the water
totally cut us off from the outside
world
gotta admit though if i have to be stuck
on an island full of vampires i'm glad
it's with y'all feelings mutual i guess
oh thanks jacob
we've also got remy our engineer genius
and her little robot buddy
who's a good robot who's the best robot
and our resident experts on all things
creepy i prefer the term cryptozoologist
but to each their own last but not least
yours truly i have these weird
powers
we've been digging for answers but
haven't found much beyond blood and
death luckily the vampires and their
sycophants aren't discreet about where
they like to nest i'd bet the answers we
need are inside those tourist traps
turned fortresses
spotted some bloodsuckers in their fan
club near the festival grounds let's
start there
ghosting out
[Music]
cultists could go straight at them or
just slip past
let's just get this done
on my mark
oh [__] bloodbath
i know we're here look alive
this one is mine going up
my cryptid hunter's intuition tells me
there's a nest nearby you're what duff
that's not a thing
found something oh now i simply must go
in there what is that
where does it go
some kind of collective consciousness
that's impossible
[Music]
there's the movie theater i used to come
here all the time why'd they have to
mess this up for me
oh
[__] alive it'll collapse any seconds
is
[Applause]
[Music]
what
hey
[Music]
um
oh
[Music]
selling humans is drugs you're the only
one that can stop them
realize we're gonna have to take out the
entire alien drug cartel
you're just gonna leave me here in in
what space everybody lives in space
including you
all right you're a bounty hunter now
you've got to help me rescue my friends
they're gatherings just like me
hey why are you squeezing me so tight
how about a little dinner first and some
bubble bath maybe first look at us
blasting away
oh yeah that's one of my children they
died back don't worry it's easy to make
more
[Music]
yes more more i need more stabbing
everyone bite each other
[Laughter]
[Music]
well okay well now
well now i sorta now i can
welcome to the xbox and bethesda games
showcase today we're doing something
we've never done before for the first
time ever our entire show is focused on
games you can play over the next 12
months you're going to see more gameplay
than we've ever had in a show industry
defining racing experiences gripping
narratives compelling strategy titles
and
my favorite the most anticipated open
world rpg of the last 20 years
all playable in the year ahead
[Music]
and the best part is with the xbox
you'll be able to play those games in
more ways than ever before you can play
on your console pc you're on the go with
xbox cloud gaming you can play with who
you want where you want and when you
want
today we're going to show you more than
30 titles that are coming to game pass
and that is on top of the hundreds of
titles coming to members over the next
year
our next announcement shows that the
benefits of game pass go well beyond the
console
we are thrilled to be working with an
iconic team that has built some of the
most played most watched franchises in
the entire world
and now
all game pass members will be able to
unlock the benefits for these incredible
games on pc and mobile
for over a decade players have created a
thriving culture of competition and
creativity around our games from clutch
plays with friends to unforgettable
moments in esports to amazing creations
that have blown our minds our community
has continually taken riot games to new
heights
today we're proud to invite the xbox
community into that world we're bringing
our biggest pc and mobile games to game
pass
subscribers will unlock every champion
on league and wild rift all valorem
agents select cards and legends of
frontera and little legends in team
fight tactics
and that's just the start
thank you for coming on this journey
with us and welcome to riot games
[Music]
home sweet home
them how we do it every day
is
[Music]
know
[Applause]
i'm sorry i miss
you for hugo
he's not dead yet
[Music]
the macula is not just in hugo's blood
it concerns everybody
and it can change everything
no no no no no
from
remember no more killing soldiers no
more killing us
[Music]
look out there's a killer around here
one of our men has been murdered
[Music]
you're only making it worse
unless you don't
i'm tired of being afraid i'll show them
that it's over finally
see they're nothing nothing to be
no you are scared them what is wrong
with me
[Music]
um
then you can call me
[Music]
but similar to the letters no one could
do it better
you can blame sean but i ain't inventing
the game
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm
[Music]
forza motorsport is back i'm dan
greenwald gm of motorsport and i'm
joined by chris sasaki creative director
at turn 10.
forza is known for its photo real beauty
and state of the art immersion
built from the ground up to showcase the
xbox series x and s consoles
including techniques like real-time ray
tracing on track
this is the most technically advanced
racing game ever made
today
we're excited to show you the all-new
forza motorsport
welcome to maple valley
this track has been a fan favorite since
the original motorsport launched back in
2005.
for the first time in forza motorsport
fully dynamic time of day brings maple
valley to life in stunning detail
what you are seeing is an in-engine
gameplay demo presented using a single
camera with no cuts
let's jump in with the m8
we've completely overhauled the driving
experience
this includes a 48 times improvement in
the fidelity of our physics simulation
let's advance time of day here and look
at the world details
everything you see is new and has been
captured with photogrammetry and 3d
material scans
advanced rendering and procedural
generation techniques bring a new level
of realism to the track
[Music]
here you can see the beautiful fall
colors of maple valley
the grass
rocks 3d vegetation skies and clouds
they all demonstrate a generational leap
in beauty and detail
let's advance time again
you are looking at our all-new dynamic
time of day
[Music]
this is a fundamental system to the new
forza motorsport
and like weather is available on every
track
these new simulation details add further
depth drama and dynamics to the racing
experience
in addition to our dynamic time of day
forward plus lighting and physically
based lights come together to deepen the
realism and immersion in the world
changes in the time of day also change
ambient temperatures which affect track
surface temps
grip is also affected by these track
temp changes
rubbering in and of course weather
let's head to the pits
we've added features that players have
been asking for
tire and fuel management multiple tire
compounds and new depth in car building
create the ultimate racing playset
advanced materials and shaders paired
with ray tracing bring out incredible
detail in the gold heat wrap anodized
aluminum and carbon fiber
engine bays with their complex
self-reflection is a place where ray
tracing
really shines
car damage is a racing reality
in forza motorsport
car damage is reproduced down to the
individual scratches on the body work
you can see here some of the new details
in the directionality of damage how the
paint peels away at exposed and raised
edges
in the wheel abrasions and even in the
dirt buildup
using the power of the xbox series x and
s consoles
ray tracing makes everything feel more
connected
cars reflecting onto other cars
cars reflect in their own mirrors
bodywork brake rotors and wings
[Music]
things just feel more natural
more real
we believe that the accuracy of our
overhaul physics
the beauty of our cars and tracks
our new dynamic time of day
advanced car damage and real time ray
tracing on track
lead to a generational leap in immersion
this
is the all-new
forza motorsport
[Music]
[Applause]
which one's your favorite
mine's tracer
she's like she's not the cavalry's here
you're one of those heroes aren't you
before me i see the future
human
machine
you know there's more out there
don't you
even the best journeys and
but a new one
is right around the corner
[Music]
i am your queen
let's take him to the wasteland
one punch is all i need
[Music]
nice work team
keep it moving
i cannot wait to push
you back
boom baby
[Music]
takes a team to tango
surprise
you like this one
what type
[Applause]
[Music]
no wastelander
has ever made it to the reckoning before
[Applause]
but here i am
a
free-for-all with zero rules
[Applause]
and the survivor
gets the throne
[Music]
king howell
has never lost
not in 13 years of rule on the
battlefield
but
not until
today
did you really think this would be a
fair fight
[Music]
history is filled with moments of
greatness
some well-known some lost to time
but what about the history that could
have been if you were its architect
how would you reshape the world
what new stories would you tell
and when your people speak
would you listen
how would you lead them in this new
world
[Music]
history is filled with moments of
greatness
but these will be yours
it's good to be here celebrating what's
going to be our biggest year yet
that includes a few of the projects
being developed across bethesda's eight
studios starting with red fall and the
world's first look at gameplay earlier
in the show
red falls from the studio that brought
us dishonored and prey it's got so much
of arcane's dna coursing through its
veins compelling heroes open world
campaign deep customization solo or with
friends we can't wait for you to play
red fall when it releases early next
year
if you're looking for something to sink
your teeth into right now we've got the
elder scrolls online where you can
adventure alongside one of the biggest
and most welcoming communities in gaming
this year zenimax online studios is
taking you somewhere that has never been
explored in any elder scrolls game the
elder scrolls online high isle comes the
xbox next week
for generations
the breton elite have lived in safety
and comfort
but now
the embers of descent glow beneath the
pomp and circumstance
[Applause]
and whispers of a sinister plot
stoke the flames of war
[Music]
at the heart of the conflagration
sits the ascendant lord
[Music]
the legacy of the presence
must be protected
fallout turns 25 this year as we
celebrate the legacy of this storied
franchise bethesda game studios takes
fallout 76 players out of appalachia for
the first time and returns to a beloved
location expedition's the pit is coming
this september
[Music]
and you're brave enough
come join us at the pit
your rival is the first good news we've
had in a while it might not look like
much
this place is our home and together we
can take it back
from these rad worshipping fanatics
[Music]
bethesda game studios has been busy and
not just with fallout 76 after defining
the role-playing genre with hits like
morrowind oblivion skyrim fallout 3 and
fallout 4 they're going even bigger with
starfield
later in the show my good friend todd
howard will be here to reveal more of
their next epic rpg
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
where the yeah are far behind
the rainbow
[Music]
[Applause]
my dad tells stories of a terrible war
that happened across the sky
heroes fought
and died
to give us a chance to start over
[Applause]
all that i know from their earth are the
creatures they sent along with us
[Applause]
and here on iraq every day is a fight to
survive
[Music]
but if anyone can tame this new world we
can
[Music]
when the gods first emerged from the
great below
we saw them as saviors
[Music]
instead they unleashed a pestilence on
our world
no one yet knows if you can kill a god
i for one
intend to find out
[Music]
foreign
oh
[Music]
legends hold great power
they are the dreams we weave
into our shared story
some legends tell of peace
and the beauty of simplicity
[Music]
some tell of danger
and the end of all things
[Music]
but the legends we hold dearest
are legends of hope
of creativity
and of bravery
and friendships
that change the world forever
[Music]
this is the legend of a united
over world
united
by you
[Music]
[Applause]
i remember when you first arrived
you made quite the entrance
you wanted to make a new life for
yourself
[Music]
and while you explored
you uncovered a mystery
i'm sure we can get to the bottom of
this
together
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
hello anyone here
i got a bad feeling about this
since i found the first piece
there must be more
[Music]
that's him
my father i can guide you through his
memories
[Music]
we're close
don't let your fight hold you back now
[Music]
it is good to see you
hold yourself together benedict
bonjour everyone i am excited to be here
today to tell you more about interior
knight's first original creation as
those falls
it started with the desire to create a
deep interactive experience
all levels of players can enjoy to gap
because stories are brilliant universal
tools that help us understand the
heartbreaking beauty of life
this game is an uncompromising tale of
family resilience and sacrifice written
like a prestige tv show with a unique
motion graphic novel style that triggers
the imagination
this is an interactive story powered by
video games that gives you agency over
the lives of far from perfect human
beings
this is a thought-provoking experience
you can play with people you love
discover insights about each other and
create shared memories
as dustfuls is an emotional experience
that we hope will leave a mark with
everyone who plays it
[Music]
for most people
to rock is just a pit stop
[Music]
wasn't taking the scenic route your idea
but for us it felt like a trap there's
enough cash in that safe to put the last
few weeks behind us
on the ground now
you were in the wrong place at the wrong
time
we've been in the wrong place forever
sometimes doing the right thing is doing
the wrong thing
[Music]
none of us escaped that night
it's okay
even those of us who made it out alive
stop
why are you following me
you've taken very different paths in
life
[Music]
but they all lead back to two rock
get rid of the cop
[Music]
hey there
evening hey sam
say uh you haven't seen three fellas in
a blue pickup have you nope
been here all day i ain't like in the
desert dream oh uh
can't complain can i uh ask what brings
you to two rock
[Music]
so
now
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
kids are you ready for a new wild and
wacky fruit
[Applause]
special breaking report more local
teenagers have gone missing this could
be linked to the disturbing trend of
missing teenagers from our otherwise
quiet town
if anyone has seen the teenagers or has
any other information please contact the
police department
hello micro friends
but that can be repaired
first
you will need to survive the yard
against terrifying insects
and treacherous wastelands
unfortunately my memory [__] is a little
rusty
but with a little maintenance
we can unravel
why you are here
before someone or something
terminates your tiny existence
[Music]
good luck
so
[Music]
helios
they search for someone who does not
exist
the shadow
the forgotten child
of a scattered race
lost
until now
now they have awakened the erebin
now they have awakened me
but i am not their hope
i
am their reckoning
[Music]
they will not drag me into their light
because their light
is a lie
i speak now
to those who heed a darker cold
those bold enough cross the line of sin
for deeper knowledge
who follow an unquenchable
yearning
born of blood and bone
to unlock
the forbidden
secrets and foulest black rituals
calling for life
from death
[Music]
embrace this power
you must take it into the world
you will be shunned
scorned
marked as a living sacrifice
to this profane knowledge
[Music]
you will be a priest of rathma
a necromancer
and you will not confront the darkness
alone
we are the speakers of the dead
and the dead
have no mercy
[Music]
i'm very excited to announce our fifth
and final class
the necromancer a commander of the
undead who joins the other iconic
classes around the campfire in diablo iv
these include the mighty barbarian the
elemental sorceress the crafty rogue and
the powerful druid and you'll want them
because the demon lilith the daughter of
hatred has returned and spreading
corruption and evil as she fights to
reclaim our dark gothic world as her own
and it's up to you to stop her
now diablo 4 is the culmination of the
25 year history of the franchise
building on top of the best of what's
come before with some you know unique
twists all its own
so let's dig a little deeper by watching
for the first time i might add some xbox
series x gameplay
well hearing from a few of the many
people behind the game
[Music]
diablo 4 is the next generation of
action rpg
melding monster slaying and loot
collecting with a fully realized open
world
it's not for the faint of heart
it's gory and
unnerving it's creepy
diablo 4 is all about player choice
it takes all of the pillars of the
diablo game and just expands them
with all the new features that people
really love and appreciate in modern
games
[Music]
whoever you see yourself being you can
create in diablo for
it's important to include robust
character customization because then i
can play the fantasy that i want to play
it allows you to
switch around your playstyle as well
everything feels very powerful and fun
one of the really cool things about
having an open world is your journey
that you take throughout diablo 4 is
your own
there's no linear path that you have to
follow
we've got almost 150 dungeons in the
game
there's all kinds of surprises as you're
exploring
strongholds are an enemy territory that
you need to reclaim
you might have a space that begins as a
hostile area
but after you've cleared it out the evil
in this place has been cleansed it now
becomes a friendly town
sometimes it's a new town sometimes it's
a new dungeon
there's a whole bunch of rewards that
you get and you have a real impact on
the world as a result
no you can't leave us here they might
come back any moment local events are
really cool little story segments that
happen within the open world you'll just
be running through the world and then a
local event will pop up and you can
choose to participate in it
or get a group together and just wail on
these like giant world bosses
these are events that take a lot of
people and you really have to work
together
being able to see all the players on
your screen collaborating trying to take
this big monster down it's it's epic
it's so easy to create a community it
makes diablo more of a social experience
we've got fully enabled cross play if
you have an xbox and your buddy has a pc
you're going to be able to group up
where you can play couch co-op two
people on a couch can sit there and have
a great experience
we've created specific zones where
players can engage in pvp
if you go there you can start swinging
away at people
but you're also opening yourself up to
being swung at
if you're like really really good the
game actually marks you as like a
champion on the map
you basically become a loot pinata and
everyone wants to chase you down
the last story mission is really the
beginning of a whole different part of
the journey
now you're set up for the end game and
that end game is rich with things to do
that allow you to get more and more
powerful whether it's new items or new
dungeons or new paragon boards every
single time you come back to play diablo
4 there's going to be new stuff for you
to experience
and it's something we're going to
support for years to come
i'm really excited for folks to get
their hands on diablo 4.
just to see millions of people really
enjoying the different options through
the campaign local events couch co-op
and game pvp it almost doesn't end
and we are so close
[Music]
we brought updates that were free
to those who sail the sea though there's
always more potential within
and as this song will spell out there's
plenty to sing about
now that you can finally be a captain
can you imagine
owning your own ship
decorated with what you acquire
then to satisfy your vanity as long as
there's no profanity you can name it
just how you desire
oh
to
set sail as a pirate captain
the spotlight new features we proclaim
or to set sail as a pirate captain
that's why we really think that you
should play this game and it's available
with xbox game festivals
as a pirate captain adventure will come
knocking on your door
all to set sail as a pirate captain
and you'll be amazed at what we have
before the choice is yours whatever
[Music]
[Applause]
so
come set sail as a pirate captain
[Music]
[Applause]
to see your thieves
[Music]
uh
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
i found you
bearer of the internal elixir field
[Music]
[Applause]
japan is the home to some of the most
talented and well-known game creators
anywhere in the world
we're thrilled to be working with koei
tecmo to bring woe long fallen dynasty
to game pass
day one
i'm also excited to be working with team
ninja it was a long history of building
incredible action games for xbox and
it's great to be working with them once
again we know how important it is to our
fans to continue to bring more japanese
franchises to xbox
i'm excited to announce the return of
one of the most highly requested and
beloved franchises to xbox from our
partners
at atlas
[Music]
i'm
oh
[Music]
break away
now we know that love will change
now i'm excited to announce
a special partnership between xbox game
studios and one of the greatest creative
minds and innovators in our industry
someone that i have admired for many
years
today i'm pleased to share
we will be working together to create a
brand new experience like we've never
seen before
thank you
this is
xbox
to have kojima productions working with
our teams at xbox game studios
today for the first time ever we have
focused on showing you games that you
can play over the next 12 months
today's show celebrates a diverse lineup
of global game creators of all sizes
who bring with them
unlimited potential
games from these creators will be coming
to game pass every single month
including naraka bladepoint as dust
falls a plague tail requiem pentamete
persona 5 royale summerville and scorn
just to name a few
and we start 2023 with the launches of
some of the most anticipated titles from
the teams at xbox in bethesda
redfall minecraft legends starfield
forza motorsport and more
this has been an incredible year as we
achieved record growth across console
and game pass with millions of people
playing our games every single day
and we have you to thank for that
whether that's new players joining us
through xbox cloud gaming or our longest
bands playing on xbox and pc
we could not have done this without you
a year ago we welcomed the talented
studios at bethesda softworks to xbox
their teams have been hard at work
bringing their franchises to game pass
shipping updates to their games and
building new experiences for you to
enjoy
we know that everyone has been eager to
see starfield
our show today has highlighted game play
so it's only fitting that we end it with
an extended first look at one of the
most anticipated games in xbox history
this is starfield
[Music]
control is this constellation starship
frontier
we're ready to start on your signal
[Music]
exit vector course
steady till ready
coordinates input plotting jump course
guys has converged we're looking good
four
[Music]
it's hard to express how excited all of
us at bethesda are to be here with you
today we're so grateful you're spending
the time and we know you've waited a
long time to finally see
starfield it's easily our most ambitious
game ever like our previous games it's
an epic role-playing game where you get
to be who you want and go where you want
but this time you'll be exploring space
so let's jump right in this is early in
the game as you arrive on the mysterious
moon of crete
[Music]
according to the scanners the abundant
research facility is in this direction
[Music]
um
it would appear that pirates of the
crimson fleet are using the facility
no one's getting
hey there you are
[Music]
huh
you're gonna pay for that
[Music]
after some initial encounters you're
invited to join constellation who in the
future the game is set in are the last
group of space explorers to meet them
you'll head to the capital city of new
atlantis
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to constellation we have a lot
to talk about
we're all here because we're committed
to the biggest question of all
what's
out there
these artifacts could be everything
we've been looking for
as to what they are
what they're building
[Music]
you'll be part of solving that puzzle
now
so you found something the new guy found
it
you dug up the artifact right that means
you saw it the visions
the artifact you found appears to be one
of many scattered across the galaxy if
we can find more we can unlock their
secrets beautiful isn't it the man who
sold me this told me that it spoke to
him of course the settle systems is full
of groups with other priorities
that's the crimson fleet everybody get
ready the fleet doesn't follow the rules
agree to work for uc system together we
take down this cutthroat pirates
we're not just here to shoot the bad
guys we're peacekeepers we protect the
people of the freestar collective
when you sign up with the crimson fleet
no one quits
the only way out
is death
the path ahead may be dangerous
but we are not stopping
most dusties don't even make it this far
because whatever lies at the end of this
road
will change humanity
forever
that gives you a look at the stories in
starfield but ultimately it's not our
story it's the story you create by who
you are and the choices you make and
that starts with character creation
[Music]
it's our most flexible yet
you can customize all the elements of
how you look
you'll pick a background that gives you
three starting skills
[Music]
says here you spend some time as a
diplomat having a way with words might
prove useful
there are optional traits and these come
with unique advantages and disadvantages
but it's not just in how you can look
and how your character plays and
develops
[Music]
the skill system combines the best from
our previous games
and you can unlock new skills as you
level up and then you rank those skills
up by using them and completing
challenges
and there's deep crafting systems from
running research projects with resources
you find
to crafting weapon mods needed to
survive
and you can build your own outposts
these act as a home away from home for
survival and resource generation
you can choose where and how to build
each one
and you can hire characters you meet to
keep it up and running
but
that's not all
[Music]
you can even build your own spaceships
you can choose crew members
and yes you can completely customize the
look and layout
there's loads of different modules ship
manufacturers and more
i have to say it's so cool we just
absolutely love
this it's not just how the ship looks
it's how it performs from engines to
shields to weapon systems
because yes
you can fly it
[Music]
we can't wait for all of you to
experience the game thanks again for
being with us today and thanks for all
the support you've given us over the
decades especially on this game it's
been an incredible journey for us making
it but we know
that's really only the beginning for
it's when all of you play it that the
real journey
begins and you may be wondering just how
big is this game
so we thought we'd take one last moment
and show you
let's take a look at one of our planets
jemisin
you can land in new atlantis
but you can also land and explore
anywhere on the planet
and it's not just this planet
it's all the planets in the system
from barren but resource heavy ice balls
to goldilocks planets with life
and not just this system
but over a hundred systems
over one thousand planets
all open for you to explore
we can't wait
to see what you find
[Music]
this is
[Applause]
the time is now
but never
[Music]
is moment
it's time
[Music]